et la vie politique est tel qu encore
une fois cette semaine certains enjeux
sont passés sous le radar pour en
discuter et donc je joins marie hélène
tremblay yves malo de nos bureaux
parlementaire de québec et d'ottawa bon
dimanche à vous deux bonjour d'abord
marie-hélène encore une fois à québec
une commission parlementaire qui est
passée inaperçue
deux fois plutôt qu'une effectivement il
ya les membres de la commission
parlementaire sur la situation à des
femmes autochtones qui a terminé cette
semaine la première partie de ces
travaux parlementaires en écoutant des
représentants des différents ministères
du québec qui donne et fournissent des
services aux autochtones à travers le
québec
il devait aussi entendre des
représentants du gouvernement fédéral
mais qui se sont finalement désistés et
qui ont plutôt choisi d'envoyer un
mémoire aux membres de la commission
alors maintenant on va s'enclencher la
deuxième étape des travaux de cette
commission parlementaire les députés
vont se rendre sur le terrain dans les
communautés autochtones à travers le
québec
selon la députée du parti québécois
carole poirier ça devrait se faire tout
ça d'ici le printemps
reste que la députée du parti québécois
emmanuel a quand même certaines réserves
elle craint que les travaux soient en
quelque sorte mis en veilleuse
parce que la commission mise en place
par le gouvernement fédéral cette
fameuse enquête nationale sur les femmes
autochtones assassinées et disparues va
prendre évidemment beaucoup de place on
sait les ministres sont en tournée
actuellement travers le pays
alors elle rappelle l'importance de
cette commission ici au québec
justement d'assurer de meilleurs
services aux femmes autochtones qui en
ont bien besoin
il ya le ministre lui des affaires
autochtones geoffrey kelley qui ne
partagent pas tout à fait ces craintes
de la députée du parti québécois il
pense que l'exercice en fait et
complémentaires et que ce ne viendra pas
court circuiter en quelque sorte les
travaux qui seront faits ici au québec
alors bref on connaîtra le calendrier
justement de sept de ses déplacements
dans les réserves autochtones au cours
des prochaines semaines
merci et vous de votre côté on peut dire
soupir de soulagement chez les
organismes de bienfaisance qui était
visé par revenu canada
oui absolument
écoutez mercredi dernier la nouvelle
ministre du revenu national madame diane
bouthillier annoncé la fin du programme
de vérification des activités politiques
des organismes de bienfaisance cette
mesure avait été adoptée par le
gouvernement harper et avait été perçue
à l'époque comme étant un geste
d'intimidation envers les organismes de
bienfaisance qui critiquaient le
gouvernement on disait qu'on voulait les
réduire au silence dans le budget de
2012 mesure était présentée et je cite
pour améliorer la transparence est
exigée aux organismes de bienfaisance de
fournir de plus amples renseignements
sur leurs activités politiques et sur
leur financement qui provient de
l'étranger plusieurs estimé emmanuel à
l'époque le gouvernement par cette
mesure
voulait surtout bâillonner les
organismes qui faisaient la promotion de
l'environnement des droits de la
personne et de la réduction de la
pauvreté
quelques chiffres en terminant il y à 86
mais l'organisme de bienfaisance au
canada 500 dans leurs déclarations à
d'impôt faisait état d'activités
politiques
à ce jour il ya eu 30 vérification et
cinq avaient vu leur permis révoqué
ils ont droit d'appel très bien merci à
vous deux je sais vous allez veiller au
grain tout au long de la semaine
prochaine merci roi